mes chers collègues nous entendons ce
matin Monsieur Thierry guimbaau actuel
directeur général de voie navigable de
France et candidat proposé par le
Président de la République pour occuper
les fonctions de président de l'Autorité
de régulation des transports la RT en
application de l'article 13 de la
Constitution vous en doutez cette
audition est très attendue je rappelle
que depuis l'expiration du mandat de
Bernard Roman expiration qui a pris
effet le 1er at 2022 et le désistement
de Marc papinuti en février 2023 ce
poste est resté vacant plus de 16 mois
nous détenons probablement là un triste
record je regrette la durée excessive de
cette vacan de poste préjudiciable aux
bonnes relation que le Sénat entretient
avec le régulateur depuis sa création il
appartiendra notamment au futur
président de veiller à la qualité des
échanges avec les parlementaires
concernant les évolutions
législative relative à la
RT depuis lors c'est notre ancien
collègue Philippe Richert vice-président
et membre du collège de la RT qui ass
sur l'intérim de cette autorité publique
indépendante comme vous le savez cette
nomination ne peut intervenir qu'après
l'audition de la personne pressenties
devant les commissions compétentes de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
auditions qui doivent être suivies d'un
vote je rappelle que cette nomination ne
pourra intervenir si l'addition des
votes négatifs de chaque
commission présentait au moins les 35è
des suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions cette audition est publique
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et retransmis sur le site du Sénat à
l'issue nous procéderons bien entendu au
vote à bulletin secret je vous rappelle
qu'il ne peut y avoir de délégation de
vote et que le dépouillement doit être
effectué simultanément à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat à cet égard je
précise que la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire de
l'Assemblée nationale vous entendra tout
à l'heure je cède sans plus tarder la la
parole à notre rapporteur Philipp
Tabarot qui va conduire cette audition
vous pourrez ensuite nous présenter
votre candidature et nous faire part de
vos motivations avant de répondre aux
premières questions de notre de notre
rapporteur Franck Derlin puis mes
collègues sénateurs vous interrogeront à
leur tour pour une séquence de questions
réponse monsieur le rapporteur Tabarot
vous avez la
[Musique]
parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Gambo avant toute chose je me dois de
vous dire que nous attendions comme l'a
dit le président longjau cette audition
depuis longtemps trop longtemps je suis
bien évidemment heureux de vous
retrouver pour une audition comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le fait régulièrement
ces dernières années mais je suis aussi
surtout soulagé qu'un candidat nous soit
enfin proposé pour occuper les fonctions
de président de l'Autorité de régulation
des transports comme l'a souligné
président de la commission nous nous
sommes beaucoup inquiétés de cette
longue vacance de près d'un an et demi
depuis la fin du mandat de Bernard Roman
au 1er août 2022 je tiens au passage à
rendre hommage à son action et à sa
combativité en tant que président de la
RT si rien a priori ne semblait nous
rapprocher qu'il s'agisse de notre
orientation politique ou de notre
origine géographique je tiens à saluer
ici le courage l'esprit d'indépendance à
toute épreuve et la ténacité dont il a
su faire preuve tout au long de sa
présidence de l'autorité cela étant dit
je ne peux m'empêcher de m'interroger
sur la durée de cette vacance et je
salue d'ailleurs l'intérim assuré par
Philippe Richert sur cette période
comment faut-il d'après vous interpréter
ces 16 mois d'attente pour
l'autorité pardonnez-moi de vous poser
la question de façon aussi crue mais
faut-il finalement comprendre
que l'autorité dont vous briguez la tête
n'aurait en définitive peut-être pas
besoin d'un président vous n'êtes pas
responsable de cette situation mais je
souhaiterais recueillir votre avis sur
cette période de nomination aussi longue
qu'elle a été
rquambolesque je fais ici bien sûr
référence à la candidature de Marc
papinouti qui avait été proposé à ces
mêmes fonctions avant de se désister la
veille au soir de son audition
après la question pourquoi nommer un
président aussi tard j'en viens à ma
deuxième question pourquoi devrionsnous
vous nommer aux fonctions de président
de la
RT en premier lieu la fonction de
président de la RT
suppose une certaine connaissance des
secteurs régulés je ne doute pas de vos
compétences techniques contte tenu de
votre parcours vous avez notamment
travaillé à Aéroport de Paris au
Syndicat des transports d'île-defance
France rebaptisé île-de-fance mobilité
vous avez également occupé de 2011 à
2017 je crois les fonctions de directeur
des services de transport de la
Direction générale des infrastructures
des transports et de la mer la fameuse
DGITM au ministère de l'écologie tous
les interlocuteurs avec qui j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger ces dernières ces
derniers jours pour préparer votre
audition souligner vos compétences
techniques j'ai moi-même eu l'occasion
de le vérifier notamment tant rapporteur
budgétaire pour avis sur les crédits
relatifs au transports ferroviair
fluviaux et maritimes je tiens
d'ailleurs à souligner la qualité de nos
échanges pour laquelle vous avez
toujours répondu présent pour autant je
souhaiterais savoir dans quelle mesure
certaines des fonctions que vous avez pu
occuper au cours de votre carrière sont
de nature à rendre nécessaire un déport
ou non de votre part dans le cas où vous
seriez nommé président de la RT c'est là
l'un de nos l'une de nos principales
réserves c'était l'une de nos
principales réserves à l'égard de la
candidature de Marc papinouti en second
lieu et c'est là un point central la
présidence de la RT suppose non
seulement des compétences techniques
mais aussi et surtout une grande
indépendance ce doit être là notre
obsession mes chers collègues le futur
président de l't aura en tout état de
cause un devoir
d'ingratitude vis-à-vis du pouvoir qui
le
homme aussi compte tenu de votre rôle de
serviteur de l'État je m'interroge sur
votre capacité et même votre appétence
si vous étiez nommé président de
l'Autorité à prendre position à monter
au créneau voire même à tenir tête au
gouvernement d'après vous pourquoi votre
profil on va le dire plutôt
administratif serait-il le meilleur et
pourquoi en particulier serait-il
meilleur qu'un profil
plus politique pour permettre à la RT de
remplir ses missions en la matière nous
aurions eu au Sénat et même dans cette
commission des personnalités très
compétentes pour exercer ses
fonctions ainsi que le résumé Bernard
Roman dans son bilan de ces 6 années à
la tête de la RT il ne peut exister de
régulateurs forts et respectés à même
d'apporter la valeur qui est attendue de
lui aux US des transports sans
indépendance l'autorité a en effet
démontré sa capacité àorter un discours
courageux et à formuler des décisions
majeures portant règlement des
différents entre certaines autorités
organisatrices de la mobilité et SNCF
voyageurs dans le secteur du transport
ferroviaire comme dans le secteur
aéroportuaire ou autoroutier les
décisions de la RT sont autant de jalons
pour nos po
en matière de
mobilité la parole de Bernard romain
était également très libre il n'avait
d'ailleurs pas manqué de qualifier le
dernier contrat de performance entre
SNCF réseau et l'État d'occasion manqué
P pensez-vous pouvoir être en capacité
demain de vous exprimer avec la même
liberté quel regard portez-vous par
exemple sur cette dernière actualisation
du contrat de
performance si la multiplication des
autorités des agences questionnent
véritablement la performance de nos
politiques publiques la RT occupe par
son usage une place à part et bénéficie
d'une légitimité à toute épreuve au
regard du travail
effectué son bon fonctionnement suppose
d'avoir des moyens suffisants pour
exercer l'ensemble de ces
missions l'autorité a vu son champ de
compétenence considérablement
s'élargir les autoroutes concédé et le
transport interurbain par autocar sont
entrés dans le champ de la régulation en
2015 j'en profite pour évoquer un sujet
d'actualité en deux mots que pensez-vous
de la fermeture prévue de la gare
routière de bercissen et je crois que
notre collègue Franck dersin aura une
question très précise à vous poser
également sur ce sujet les missions de
la RT ont également été étendues au
secteur aéroportuaire en 2019 9 sous
l'effet de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités en août la loi d'adu euh en
2021 lui a confié une mission de suivi
économique et financier des aérodromes
entrant dans son champ de compétence et
plusieurs missions de suivi du service
européen de télépéage l'autorité régule
désormais six secteurs avec un plafond
de 102 équivalents temps plein
travailler et une subvention pour charge
de service public de 15 millions d'euros
prévu par le projet de loi de finan pour
2024 cette situation contraint la RT à
prélever sur son fond de roulement qui
s'en trouve désormais asséché à terme le
risque est que le régulateur n'ait plus
les moyens de faire face à d'éventuels
contentieux année après année nous
déposons avec nos collègues Olivier
Jacquin Hervé gilet Jacques ferernque
des amendements visant augmenter ses
moyens serez-vous aussi prêt à vous
battre pour obtenir davantage de moyens
pour l'autorité je ne voudrais pas qu'on
deux situations incomparables mais
j'observe que VNF pour des raisons que
nous connaissons a vu ses effectifs se
réduire à pot de chagrin ces dernières
années voilà Monsieur le candidat les
premières questions que je souhaitais
vous poser je sais que mes collègues ne
manqueront pas d'en faire autant le
contrôle du Parlement sur les
nominations n'est plus une simple
formalité comme nous l'avons démontré
précédemment des candidats ont pu s'en
rendre compte à leur dépend
bien merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs d'abord un premier mot pour
vous dire je suis évidemment très honoré
d'être parmi vous ce matin suite à la
proposition du Président de la
République de me nommer président de
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
cette proposition est évidemment un
honneur pour pour moi elle a aussi
beaucoup de sens pour moi à titre
personnel tant j'ai bâti ma carrière sur
les sujets transport pour
l'essentiel je suis on est aussi je
pense à un moment stratégique des
transports c'était sous-jacent à
certaines de vos questions monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur j'aborde cette
proposition avec beaucoup d'humilité en
même temps avec une profonde humilité
parce que je sais le rôle essentiel de
cette autorité et vous l'avez dit à
travers vos questions auquel je
répondrai bien sûr monsieur le monsieur
le rapporteur c'est une institution qui
a beaucoup évolué progressé et qui est
respecté et le le rôle du président je
vais y revenir c'est de maintenir cette
qualité et ce et ce respect si vous
permettez je dirais peut-être pour
rebondir sur votre propos un mot rapide
de mon expérience parce que je pense
qu'il répond en partie aux questions que
vous évoqué par la technique que je peux
mobiliser l'indépendance c'est aussi la
capacité technique et dieuss si c'est
acteur est complexe très complexe les
acteurs nombreux je poursuivrai ensuite
mon propos liminaire sur la question
centrale que vous avez évoqué monsieur
le rapporteur que beaucoup d'entre vous
m'avez posé comme question assez
essentielle dans les discussion que j'ai
pu avoir c'est celle de l'indépendance
j'y souscris complètement j'y souscris
complètement et je vous expliquerai en
quoi je pense disposer de l'indépendance
qui est requise pour être président de
cette autorité puis enfin j'achèterai
mon propos sur les grands défi que de la
place où je suis pour l'instant j'ai pas
encore l'expertise bien sûr interne de
la RT mais je vois déjà des à mon sens
des des lignes de force importantes sur
lesquelles il faudra que le nouveau
président soit extrêmement vigilant
alors un B tout d'abord sur mon
expérience j'ai en effet vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur beaucoup
travaillé monsieur le Président vous
l'avez évoqué aussi dans le secteur du
monde des transports dans cette
dimension à la fois financière juridique
stratégique
euh économique
mais aussi c'est une particularité
peut-être de mon parcours dans ces
aspects les plus opérationnels j'ai
voulu faire de l'exploitation j'ai voulu
aller sur le terrain de manière très
régulière pour m'occuper pour
m'intéresser de près aux questions de
qualité de service et de servicees
rendus aux usagers quel qu'ils soit j'ai
commencé vous l'avez peut-être pas dit
je le dis ma carrière au ministère de
l'économie mais je le dis pourquoi parce
que je l'ai commencé comme commissaire
en charge d'enquête de
concurrence en particulier dans le
domaine des travaux publics j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure pour illustrer
peut-être ma posture à l'essue de ma
scolarité à l'École nationale
d'administration j'ai rejoint le
ministère de l'équipement de l'époque
c'est dire s'il y a certain temps où je
me suis occupé du financement de la
concession financement et concession des
autoroutes et ouvrage concédés à
l'époque on parlait de semka société
d'économie mixte concession d'autoroute
c'est vous dire si l' a coulé sous les
ponts dans C deité statutaire j'ai
ensuite rejoint effectivement Aéroport
de Paris alors établissement public au
sein duquel je me suis occupé du
pilotage de certains grand dossier
stratégique j'en évoquerai que deux
parce que ça me paraît intéressant de
l'évoquer par rapport aux problématiques
qui qui nous intéressent d'une part j'ai
été le le pilote de l'enquête publique
sur l'extension du capacité piste de
Charles de gaaule passé deux à qu pistes
c'est une très grosse enquête publique
avec beaucoup d'écoute énormément
d'écoute des des usagers et des riverins
et puis ensuite pendant 6 ans euh j'ai
pris la responsabilité de l'exploitation
de cette plateforme aéroporttoire donc
j'étais patron de l'exploitation de
l'aéroport charles- de Gaulle métier à
compéten fortement opérationnelle vous
vous en doutez extrêmement prenant de
terrain avec la gestion directe et
indirecte de milliers d'agents et le
traitement de situation de crise parfois
paroxistique extrême je veux par exemple
dire la gestion de l'accident du
Concorde euh parce que cétais à cette
époque j'étais sur le terrain et autre
exemple paroisti il y en a des beaucoup
plus calmes je vous je vous rassure
quand même la Moné en puissance de la
sûreté aéroportuaire à la suite des
attentats du 11
septembre je suis ensuite devenu
directeur en charge des sujets
d'exploitation offre de transport
qualité de service multimodalité au
Syndicat des transports î-de-fance le
STIF qui est maintenant devenu î- de
France mobilité et j'ai ensuite rejoint
après un long parcours en dehors de
l'administration administrante si je
puis dire ministère en tout cas j'ai
ensuite rejoint pendant 5 ans le
ministère effectivement au ministère des
Transports où j'ai j'étais en
particulier en charge du pilotage
peut-être certains ont connu à ce
moment-là de la loi du 4 août 4 aoû ça
ne s'invente pas 2014 pourant réforme
autoroutière réforme du secteur
ferroviaire pardon et notamment celle
qui a singulièrement renforcé les
pouvoirs de ce qui était à l'époque
l'ARAF et qui est devenu l'arafire à
cette occasion là et qui s'appelle
maintenant la RT et depuis 2017 vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur j'ai
le plaisir d'exercer les fonctions
directeur général de voie navigable de
France donc depuis bientôt 7 ans
l'opérateur national du réseau fluvial
secteur non régulé je tiens à le dire
c'est un point important certains me
connaissent bien d'ailleurs dans cette
dans C dans ce rôle
là beaucoup d'entre vous me connaissez
sans doute effectivement plus comme dans
ce poste là autant dire que les
problèmes de transport et de régulation
dans les domaines autoroutiers
aéroportuir ferroviaire de transport
urbain et interurbain et ce dans
différentes position que ce soit
concédant gestionnaire d'infrastructure
autorité organisatrice
directeur d'administration centrale j'ai
donc joué des partitions très
différentes de ma carrière au service de
de de mission et et d'intérêt très très
composite si je puis dire voilà çat donc
constitué le cœur de mon activité
professionnelle au service de l'État et
d'intérêt général j'en tire une bonne
connaissance une très bonne connaissance
des acteurs du secteur et des grandes
problématiques même si'ils ont changé
j'en suis bien conscient euh et donc une
opérationnalité rapide une
opérationnalité rapide après
effectivement un poste qui a été
longtemps inoccupé 15 16 mois je crois
elle me donne aussi je pense une forme
d'indépendance technique et
intellectuelle
j'ai suis capable de savoir un peu
parfois ce qu'il y a derrière les
dossiers pour les avoir dans d'autres
temps un peu un peu vu si je puis dire
même si encore une fois il y a très
longtemps et je voudrais insister sur ce
dernier point de l'indépendance parce
que je sais qu'il vous préoccupe à juste
titre et je partage complètement C cette
ce pointl il est en effet consubstantiel
à mes yeux et au vôrees à l'exercice et
à la loi à l'exercice d'une autorité de
régulation des transports
consubstantielle je le dis bien alors
mon indépendance d'abord elle tient la
connaissance fine des dossiers je l'ai
évoqué même si encore une fois il y a un
certain temps voire longtemps mais des
fondamentaux restent néanmoins même
s'ils ont profondément changé aussi mais
c'est pas ça le plus important mon
indépendance elle tient au fait que si
ma carrière de haut-fonctionnaire vous
avez rappelé que je viens de rappeler
est longue elle s'achève
maintenant je n'ai plus aucune
perspective de carrière au-delà de la RT
et ne serait de ce fait pas dépendant
des pressions de toute nature ou
origine d'ailleurs je ne me serais pas
porté candidat très sincèrement si tel
n'avait pas été le
cas mais c indépendance je crois qu'il
se lit aussi dans mon parcours je n'ai
jamais rejoint une entreprise ou un
établissement dont j'ai exercé la
tutelle
ou dont j'étais donneur
d'ordre je n'ai pas d'avantage
travailler dans des cabinets
ministériels je précise enfin que vrant
depuis plus de 6 ans en tant que
directeur général de VNF dans un secteur
non régulé et n'ayant pas eu connaître
dans cette période n'ayant connaître
aucun des dossiers des secteurs régulés
je ne n'auris jamais à me
déporter dans l'exercice de mon mandat
si vous m'accordez votre confiance je
n'aurais pas à me
déporterexercice de mon mandat et puis
si vous me permettez peut-être une
observation plus personnelle parce que
l'indépendance évidment d à son statut
c'est évidment d à sa position c'est
aussi d à sa personnalité vous l'avez
évoqué je pense en filigran monsieur
monsieur le rapporteur je crois avoir
fait preuve dans ma carrière assez
largement qu'il s'agisse de mener des
enquêtes de concurrence au sein des
grandes entreprises parfois difficiles
voire rugueus avec des intérêts
importants avec des sanctions
importantes qui étaient celle de
l'Autorité de la concurrence ou plus
précisément à l'époque du Conseil de la
concurrence bien évidemment il fallait
avoir une sacrée indépendance puisque le
commissaire enquêteur c'est lui qui
rapportait à titre personnel des
constats qu'il avait fait à titre
personnel qui s'agisse aussi de
participer aux premièr loges à une
opération complexe de
décentralisation quand je suis rentré
auss c'est un sttif état établissement
public rattaché au ministère des
Transports de l'époque ou équivalent
pour en faire un établissement public
local au service des élus régionaux
départementaux de toutes les
collectivités d'île-de-fance j'étais
donc dans ce point de bascule avec
d'autres mais j a joué un rôle je pense
important donc il s'est agit de changer
en fait de manière très très forte
l'ancrage de cette autorité
organisatrice et j contribué sans aucun
état d'âme parce que je servais
pleinement la structure dans lesqueles
j'étais et j'entends mon mon travail
toujours dans cet esprit-là et qu'
s'agisse enfin plus récemment de porter
les intérêts d'un établissement public
comme VNF je pense que monsieur le
rapporteur verra de quoi je parle pour
obtenir des moyens des crédits euh ou un
contrat d'objectif et de performance qui
était pas forcément acquis au départ qui
existe maintenant autant vous dire que
ces moyens ne s'obtiennent pas sans une
forte volonté indépendante de combat
parfois y compris contre combat contre
ou avec les les tutelles je n'ai jamais
eu de problème par rapport à ça je je je
joue pleinement le rôle qui est le mien
à l'instant où je suis et je n'ai à
cette égard aucune difficulté ça va soit
où j'ai aussi l'occasion de beaucoup
travailler avec le COI pour faire en
sorte que l'investissement fluvial se
multiplié par deux ce qu'il est
maintenant par rapport aux années
passées et c'était pas franchement ça
faisait une décennie que ça a reculé et
ça beaucoup changé ces derniers temps je
ne suis pas seul à l'avoir obtenu j'y ai
eu ma part néanmoins
voilà quelques points rapides qui vous
donneront j'espère un éclairage
convaincant sur cette exigence qui est
la vôtre qui est la mienne
elle est absolument essentiel sur la
position d'un président de la RT
elle est par ailleurs garantie aussi par
le statut de l'autorité c'est
indépendance elle est garantie par le
statut d'autorité par le fait que ce
poste est inamovible et que ce poste
n'est pas renouvelable il est doublement
pour moi puisque je n'ai pas de carrière
àprès c'est ce que je disais et par la
collégialité des décisions prises j'ai
eu l'occasion de discuter avec les les
vice-présidents les quatre
vice-présidents et vice-présidentes euh
les décisions se prennent de manière
extrêmement
collégiale et donc c'est pas une
décision le le président n'est pas même
s'il est là pour réguler pour animer
c'est pas lui qui prend les décisions
seul il veille toujours à prendre avec
l'ensemble des des vice-présidents ceci
étant il assure assume le rôle de porter
l'art donc il un rôle particulier
effectivement qui exige une la posture
que vous que vous avez évoqué j'espère
donc que ces éléments vous donneront un
éclairage sur cette question
d'indépendance qui pour moi me
connaissant ne fait pas l'ombre un doute
mais je comprends vos questions elles
sont légitimes alors ceci étant donc
très rapidement quels sont les grands
enjeux maintenant de de cette de cette
autorité dans ce moment stratégique pour
notre pour les transports dans notre
pays tout d'abord beaucoup d'humilité et
de prudence en ce qui me concerne malgré
ma connaissance et ma vision d'ensemble
du secteur je ne vrais pas donner
l'impression que je connais déjà tout
bien évidemment non et en particulier la
question de la régulation économique
sectorielle est un métier en soi qu'il
me faudra apprendre que je ne connais
pas encore dans ces détails loin s'en
faut mais en m'appuyant sur les membres
du collège en m'appuyant sur les
services de l'autorité et encore sur
l'ensemble des parties prenantes et en
m'appuyant également sur les discussions
que nous aurons ici même avec la
Commission au Sénat je ferai tout à
l'heure une proposition sur ce plan là
sur ce
pointlà tout de même une première
remarque s'impose je pense que la RT a
trouvé sa place
je le dis parce que j'ai connu bien
avant
le ce qui a constitué le début de la RT
si je puis dire quelques années après ce
dernier mois en ayant regardé de plus
près j'ai trouvé que cette art beaucoup
me l'ont dit à trouvé sa place la
qualité de son travail très pointu dans
les domaines juridiques économique et
technique c'est un travail très pointu
très technique mais sur laquelle sa
crédibilité
repose la solidité DEES analyses
indépendantes est très fouillé qui en
font aelà de ses missions de régulateur
de confiance pour l'ensemble des acteurs
dans la conduite des politiques
publiques qui relève de son champ de
compétence la confirmation quasi
systématique de ces décisions quand
elles sont contestées devant la justice
quasi systématique je crois que c'est
absolument remarquable et c'est donc ce
qui continue la force de cette art le
dernier rapport de la Cour des comptes
que j'ai lu le dit clairement le rapport
encore plus récent il y a quelques
semaines de l'Autorité de la concurrence
le confirme et donc je considère que le
mandat premier d'un président est sera
de préserver et de développer ses acquis
en toute
indépendance alors la RT a trouvé sa
place mais je pense qu'elle est
aujourd'hui menacée cette place et
inaboutie
elle est menacée parce que les moyens
notamment budgétaires là aussi vous
l'avez évoqué de son indépendance
commencent à manquer de manière
extrêmement
préoccupante je sais que c'est une
préoccupation forte vous l'avez vousmême
exprimé vous avez vousmême porté une
évolution sur ce planl notamment laation
budgétaire mais c'est une préoccupation
qui est vraiment pour moi qui est
essentielle en arrivant c'est ce que ce
qui m'a sauté aux yeux en premier si je
puis dire la dotation budgétaire vous
savez de cette 2023 de 14 millions pour
102 TPT vous l' rappelé elle est
totalement déconnectée des besoins d'une
autorité publique indépendante régulant
6 secteurs je le dis très clairement
devant vous en toute indépendance elle
est clairement
déconnectée le fond de roulement est
vrai é important il y a quelques années
faut le reconnaître il était légitime de
l'utiliser arrive maintenant à son
étiage je suis un peu un spécialiste de
l'étiage pas toujours monsieur le
sénateur pas toujours par des cru aussi
le fond de roulement donc a été en
grande partie asséché j'en suis d'accord
et cette menace me préoccupe beaucoup
parce qu'elle menace précisément les
capacités de la RT de renouveler ses
équipements ses systèmes d'information
de recruter des des des agents de très
haut niveau euh et de même de faire face
à ses responsabilités découlant de sa
personnalité et une personnalité
juridique sa responsabilité est engagée
elle pourrait avoir à affronter j'allais
dire les conséquences de cette
responsabilité je crains qu'elle n'en
ait pas complètement les moyens
aujourd'hui vous savez que euh la
demande est faite d'à peu près de
l'ordre de 18,6 millions d'euros de
budget d'équilibre je précise bien que
dans ce budget il y a un effort de
productivité qui est indispensable comme
tout acteur public si on faisait une
simple R de 3 on serait au-dessus de ce
budget mais je pense que c'est un aspect
qui est absolument indispensable donc
j'ajouterai aussi que ces contributions
en augmentation certes sont difficiles à
toujours à faire passer j'en sais
quelque chose je pour y revenir sur le
VNF euh mais elles sont très modestes en
valeur absolue elles sont surtout très
modestes au regard de ce que permet de
faire la RT je voudrais juste rappeler
un chiffre euh l'action de la RT a
permis d'obtenir sur les les les
avenants autoroutier une réduction de 28
millions d'euros de hausse de péage
autoroutier dans la seule année
2022 voilà donc je pense que ça n'est
pas un investissement entre guillemets
dans le dans le secteur public qui est
pas sans intérêt pour la collectivité
voilà je vous pardonnerai ce propos un
petit peu long sur les moyens mais pour
moi c'est un point stratégique que
j'assumerai pleinement et ça sera mon
rôle que de porter si vous me confirmez
ce ce cet aspect là je disais donc est
menacé est aussi outil parce que le les
compétences de la RT se sont étendu
progressivement vous l'avez
rappelé en d'huile en quelque sorte
elle a su d'ailleurs y faire face pas à
pas avec
compéten mais cela s'est fait au coup
par coup sans vision systémique de ce
qui fait l'implication de la RT ce qui
fait que l'implication de la RT
maintenant est très différente suivant
les secteurs approfondi dans le domaine
ferroviaire c'est son point d'origine
moins approfondi dans le domaine
aéroportuaire moins approfondi dans le
domaine
autoroutier il y a à l'évidenceel un
périmètre qui n'est pas qui n'a pas la
clarté que peuvent avoir d'autres
régulateurs je pense en particulier à la
à la creux je pense donc que le moment
est venu en tout cas c'est ce quoi je
m'en croiris si vous confirmez de
reposer les fondamentaux de ce qui'est
une autorité de régulation des
transports il s'agit certainement pas de
tout chambouler puisque ça marche mais
de compléter été de donner un sens
renouvelé au régulateur des réflexions
très intéressantes ont déjà été
entreprises d'ailleurs en interne de de
l'autorité et la Cour des comptes comme
l'utité de la concurrence ont rappelé
leur attente euh sur ce sujet mon projet
sera évidemment de valoriser et de
porter cette vision autour de quoi
rapidement je pense autour premièrement
de la transition écologique et
énergétique c'est elle qui nous conduit
au combien toutes et tous dans nos
actions je pense qu'un régulateur a un
rôle à jouer sur ces sujets-là même si
c'est pas un acteur de la l'écologie en
premère en premier intention reste que
le bon fonctionnement au qual veille des
systèmes de transport notamment par
exemple ferroviaire notamment les
transports collectifs évidemment est un
élément qui contribue très clairement à
la transition énergétique et écologique
je ne vous savez très bien ce qu'il en
est des gaz à effet de ser dans le
domaine des transports c'est le grand
enjeu des transports il me paraît normal
que le régulateur apporte sa
contribution euh parce qu'il est au cœur
de ces questions dans les décisions
qu'il prend dans les avis qu'il rend et
dans les études qu'il fait deuxième
grand point je pense c'est celui de la
maîtrise des prix pour préserver les
pouvoirs
d'achat et rendre les rendre les les
modes de transport collectif les plus
attractifs possibles il y a une question
de prix il a une question de de de prix
qui est importante de coût et de prix
j'entends des voix derrière moi et puis
trè question de
de très bien super il y a une trème
trème aspect qui me paraît essentiel
dans cette stratégie c'est la qualité de
service rendu aux usagers je suis
sensible je vous l'ai dit j'ai beaucoup
travaillé dans ces sujets là en direct
en tant qu'opérationnel et donc ces
éléments là transition
écologique contrôle des prix le plus
possible au départ je suis venu dans le
ministère dans le contrôle des prix
c'est vous dire et donc pouvoir d'achat
et donc attractivité et service rend
usagers me paraissent les trois angles
importants de unee évolution à venir de
la de
l'autorité dans cette perspective
stratégique il me semble important que
les pouvoirs d'intervention de la RT soi
approfondis et harmonisés ils ne le sont
pas aujourd'hui harmonisés jeai dit ils
peuvent être
approfondis encore une fois cette montée
en compéten
progressive du régulateur fait que j'ai
sentiment que le régulateur est plutôt
vu comme un régulateur des modes de
transport plutôt que comme un ré
des transports un peu mode par mode
voilà donc il me semble dans cet esprit
des initiatives pourrai être prises à
l'inur d'autres régulateur précisément
pour prévoir uniformiser approfondir ses
compétences du du régulateur ça
permettrait de fonder en quelque sorte
un nouveau pacte des de l' RT enfin pour
terminer je serais personnellement très
attaché à ce que le régulateur
approfondit son positionnement d'expert
de tiers de confiance qui va au-delà de
la
régulation d'appui auprès de tous les
pouvoirs publics qui interviennent dans
le champ des transports qu'il s'agisse
des ministères bien sûr qu'il s'agiss
d'autorité organisatrice des transports
mais aussi du Parlement mais aussi du
Parlement à cet égard si vous en êtes
d'accord je m'engage à venir
régulièrement rendre compte de l'action
de la RT et présenter ses principaux
travaux devant votre commission surivant
un rythme qui vous agréera et même je
veillerai à ce que RT puisse apporter de
la même manière des éclairages sur les
travaux parlementaires que vous
menez voilà en
résumé de ma fenêtre actuelle ce que je
vois des grands enjeux c'est bien la
préservation de l'équilibre financier et
des moyens de la RT pour être
indépendant ça sera mon combat je pense
qu'il va être encore amené quelques
temps à mon avis euh
deuxièmement de de faire en sorte que un
nouveau cas puisse être donné dans dans
le sens d'un approfondissement des
compétences et de cohérence des
compétences de la RT et troisièmement
que ce rôle de de de de conseil de tiers
de confiance à l'égard des partis et
notamment partis public parti des
pouvoirs publics soit renforcé voilà
monsieur le rapporteur voilà monsieur le
Président ce que je souhaitais dire
j'espère avoir répondu peut-être pas à
toutes les questions évoqué à l'instant
pourquoi un s long
délai premièrement je ne sais rien je ne
suis pas
pas décideur de de ce délai bien par
construction j'allis dire par contre
est-ce que ce délai a été péjorant oui
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter avec les
vice-présidents j'ai quand même senti
plus que senti qu'on était maintenant en
bout de course j'allais dire et qu'il
fallait porter d'abord 5 personnes pour
débattre des orientations qui sont
prises qui sont éidemment complexe
sensible voir effectivement qui exige
une posture forte C personnes ça n'est
pas une de trop vraiment pas et un
président est effectivement là pour
porter même si je pense qu'il faut
rendre un grand coup de chapeau
notamment à Philippe Richert qui a mené
l'intérim brillamment mais il reste que
lui-même me l'a dit il me l'a dit quand
je l'ai vu il m'a dit on attend avec
impatience l'arrivée d'un président donc
je pense qu'on ne peut pas rester si je
veux en expliquer les causes en tout cas
je puis vous dire qu'on ne peut pas
rester comme cela plus longtemps un
profil administratif un profil politique
j'ai dire je suis pas forcément bien
placé pour complètement débattre de ce
point-là c'est votre travail bien sûr
d'en d'en débattre moi je pense que com
j'ai cru vous le dire tout à l'heure
l'indépendance est tout à fait pe tout
en tout cas moi j'ai veillé dans ma
carrière je n'ai pas passé ma carrière
dans l'administration centrale en
permanence j'ai passé 10 ans elle est
elle est bien plus longue que ça cette
carrière pourquoi parce que j'ai voulu
prendre des points de vue des rôles
assumer des responsabilités parfois en
toute indépendance
différente et à chaque fois j'ai dans le
CRE des missions qui étaient les miennes
je pense avoir rempli ce rôle au mieux
sans me soucier de savoir si sans me
soucier de savoir si on
allait avoir un problème après ou pas
c'est pas mon ça jamais été mon sujet
jamais de ma vie ça n'a jamais été un
point personnel je voulais avoir ce
cette cette petite remarque personnelle
fermeture prévue de la gare on attend
peut-être la question de de Monsieur oui
ça pourra faire d'accord et puis
j'arrête là parler trop longtemps merci
je vais donner la parole à Franck derzin
oui oui effectivement ça va mieux comme
ça oui euh monsieur le Président longjon
Monsieur rapporteur monsieur guimbau
alors comme l'a sous-entendu monsieur
Tabarot c'est vrai que nous aurions aimé
avoir en face de nous un profil plus
politique euh bah parce que déjà votre
pr enfin j'allais dire votre
prédécesseur j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas celui qui est était là avant Bernard
Roman que je connaissais bien puisque
nordiste comme moi je fus député avec
lui a été un excellent président
reconnu par tous et par toutes
euh toutefois je je je dois dire que je
connais bien monsieur guimbaau pour
avoir été membre du conseil
d'administration de de VNF et que dans
ma région des haut--fan où les canaux
sont omnibi présents j'ai pu mesurer euh
la qualité monsieur guimbau de votre
travail au au sein de de VNF et je le
dis ici à tout le monde vous avez été un
excellent président de de
VNF alors j'ai tout de suite une sorte
de cas d'école à à à vous poser au cas
vous seriez je dirais nommé dans
confirmé dans vos fonctions nous avons
justement une une une CMP ce soir sur
les les les
bus parisiens
RATP euh euhî de France et euh il se
trouve que euh euh la l'homme dit
clairement que
euh votre structure est compétente pour
gérer un certain nombre euh euh de
conflits or il se trouve que peut-être
parce qu'il n'y a plus de président
depuis un bon bout de temps euh un
membre de votre administration a a
convaincu euh Jea un un député que
finalement comme il n'y avait pas assez
de
moyens il ne fallait pas que la RT
prenne une compétence que pourtant la
l'homme Mons Mandelli qui le connaî
parfaitement bien lui confie donc euh
j'avoue avoir été pas que moi assez
choqué sur cette réponse euh et et et
donc j'aimerais bien savoir justement
quel serait
votre décision collégiale hein vous
l'avez dit c'est pas que la vôtre euh
euh sur un sujet comme celui-là euh
c'est vraiment je dirais très important
pour nous ensuite j'ai j'ai une autre
question on arrive à la fin des
concessions autoroutièr enfin d'ci 2031
euh moi là-dessus enfin il va falloir
que l'on réfléchisse à l'avenir et on
aura besoin justement là-dessus de votre
travail de votre réflexion vous serez là
comme vous l'avez dit pour
nous pour nous aider pour nous faciliter
la tâche pour nous permettre de nous
prendre la bonne décision donc euh euh
voilà j'aimerais savoir comment vous
vous
envisagez ce
travail dans les années à venir à nos
côtés pour nous aider justement à
prendre ces bonnes décisions merci merci
je vais donner la parole à Jacques fnick
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur alors rapidement j'ai trois
questions mais en une minute face à
l'urgence climatique la régulation des
transports ça ne peut plus s'envisager
dans le périmètre d'objectif tel qu'on
l'envisageait autrefois donc comment
ancrer la transition écologique des
transports plus fermement dans
l'émission de l' RT est-ce qu'il faut en
clair le préciser dans la loi et pour un
des secteurs des transports je pense à
l'aéroportuire l'aérien sa régulation
pour l'accompagner dans une véritable
mutation environnementale n'apparaît pas
comme lisible et évidente comment l'art
pourrait y contribuer davantage deuxème
question pour le rail on sait l'enjeu
primordial des investissements de
régénération et modérisation d'ailleurs
votre expérience à VNF vous a confronté
à la nécessité de reprendre des
infrastructures en déclin dégradé par un
manque d'investissement pour le rail il
s'agit d'intensifier l'usage du réseau
largement moins utilisé que nos voisins
européen sous la supervision de la RT
quel levier vous paraisse devoir être
déployé pour cela cuid des péages
ferroviaires comment envisager dans sens
l'ouverture à la concurrence et comment
préserver le développement du frais tout
en tenant nos objectifs pour les
voyageurs particulièrement pour les
CERMES et pour finir justement sur les
CERMES comment envisagez-vous le
l'action de l'ARTT pour la réussite de
ces services express régionaux
métropolitains je pense à la
programmation de leurs investissements
et au financement de leurs charges
d'exploitation notamment les péages je
pense pense aussi à l'exigence de
fluidité pour des services pour les
usagers particulièrement
l'interopérabilité de laabéthique et des
services d'information d'ailleurs sur
ces trois sujets financement péage et
interopérabilité l'apport du Sénat a été
déterminant dans la proposition de
loit merci la parole est à Stéphane
demi merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur guimo vous avez répondu déjà à
des questions que je voulais vous poser
dans le cadre de vos propos introd
productif alors je vais vous poser une
question liée à à l'actualité
sénatoriale et notamment à l'actualité
budgétaire euh je voulais savoir quel
était votre avis sur la fameuse taxe
concernant les infrastructures de de
longue distance et et j'y greffe une une
deuxième question que pensez-vous de de
l'idée et cette question n'est pas
complètement désintéressée euh au regard
du fait que je suis un un élu Picard que
pensez-vous de de l'idée d'affecter ces
recettes par région
en fonction de son réseau
autoroutier merci la parole est à
Olivier
jacqu euh merci président
euh je salue monsieur le rapporteur dont
je partage les grands axes de
questionnement euh Monsieur le Directeur
euh nous sortons de 16 mois on l'espère
de vacances de la RT qui l'auront sans
aucun doute effectivement fragilisé et
c'est plus que regrettable on sait d'où
vient cette vacance trop longue euh
alors pour être rapide je tiens à saluer
l'un des meilleurs spécialistes des
transports que compte notre pays euh
pour ma part je vous ai découvert comme
directeur de VNF qui sombrait euh la
dénavigation d'une partie du réseau
grand estest était même programmé et
votre créativité votre entre gens votre
pragmatisme ont permis récemment la
signature d'une convention avec les
collectivités territoriales pour
relancer ce réseau en Grand Est et vous
l'avez fait dans d'autres régions ou
plus de manière plus détaillée je vous
ai vu à l'œuvre sur la première
convention établie autour de la loi
dididier sur un pont de rétablissement
dans un cas très difficile et complexe
et coûteux du pont de pierre l Trèche en
en meurtemoselle sans parler de la COP
si é valorisante de l'augmentation de
l'investissement alors voilà du côté de
la compétence il y a pas de souci je
suis pas inquiet des risques de déports
toute la question est effectivement
l'indépendance vous êtes un haut
fonctionnaire remarquable et un haut
fonctionnaire ça passe son temps à obéir
à un ministre merci
et la question qui est devant nous c'est
faut-il un fonctionnaire à ce poste et
permettez-moi de saluer Bernard moment
qu'il a déjà été salué par tous les
bancs et qui a véritablement installé
l'art dans son rôle par sa compétence
son autorité son charisme je vous
rappelle son
courage dans le cas des deux contrats de
performance de SNCF réseau qui l'a plus
que critiqué remis en en cause ou encore
un autre dossier récent le contournement
de Montpellier où il est entré en
opposition directe avec la DGITM sur le
coût de de prévisionnel de de l'ouvrage
et voilà et enfin pour Bernard ran il
venait régulièrement et avec plaisir
devant notre devant le Parlement vous
vous y êtes engagé également j'ai bien
entendu alors
effectivement la question j'ai envie de
vous poser devant les grands enjeux des
transports dont le premier la
décarbonation et la nécessaire
transition et je rejoins la question de
Jacques ferernck faut-il aller plus loin
dans la dans dans le législatif pour
mieux définir les missions de l'art
là-dessus ou encore l'autre enjeu c'est
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
ferroviaire qui ne fonctionne pas c'est
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui ne
fonctionne pas hein et enfin la fin des
contrats autoroutiers quel serait votre
discours de la méthode du point de vue
de la RT pour aborder cette épreuve je
l'espère très prochaine
merci merci je vais donner la parole à
Pierre Barros
oui merci monsieur le président chers
collègu Monsieur le Directeur bah on est
on est bien voisin de table en fait avec
avec les collègues parce que me propos V
prolonger ce qui a été rapporté donc 30
% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont attribué au secteur des transports
en pleine COP 28 alors que le
gouvernement annoncer son ambition de
sortir des énergies fossiles d'ici 2050
le transport ferroviaire est devenu la
pierre angulaire de la stratégie du
gouvernement en matière de réduction des
émissions vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure aussi dans votre dans votre
propos l'Autorité de régulation des
transports aura certainement un rôle
important à jouer dans ce processus un
avis de l'Autorité de la concurrence
opportunément porter notre connaissance
lundi dernier je cite met en évidence le
rôle de la concurrence dans l'atteint
des objectifs climatique durable cet
avis ajoute que la RT doit voir ses
prérogatives évoluer pour devenir un
véritable gendarme de la concurrence du
ferroviaire alors c'est vrai qu'avec les
collègues de notre groupe on souhaite
toutefois rappeler que l'ouverture à la
concurrence dans le ferroviaire est loin
de fonctionner si ces effets sont
limités ces conséquences sont bien réels
avec l'ouverture à la concurrence du
rail les activités voyageurs et
marchandises ont subi ces politiques de
dérégulation est connu des BA
d'activités conjuguées à la dégradation
du service la concentration du privé aux
seules activités rentable a eu pour
conséquence tout simplement de réduire
plus une offre de service pour pourtant
indispensable à ce titre les ang du FR
ferroviaire est frappant la part du rail
dans le transport de marchandis a été
divisé par de entre 2006 et 2019 au
profil des transports routiers bien plus
polluant les rapports du JEC nous
rappellent pourtant l'urgence qui a
lutter plus vite et plus efficacement
contre le réchauffement climatique vous
en avez parlé aussi d'autres pays ont
fait ce choix je pense à l'Écosse la
Norvège pays de Gal ou à l'Angleterre
les activités ferroviaires confié au
privés sont depuis retourné enistement
public où en passe de lettre
aujourd'hui pour tenir nos objectifs
nous avons besoin d'une politique
ambitieuse de relance du rail partout
sur le territoire en rupture avec les
les logiques libérales qui privilégieent
les tronçons les plus rentables alors
monsieur guimbau pouvez-vous vraiment
pensez-vous vraiment pardon que la
concurrence puisse nous permettre
d'atteindre notre ambition les objectifs
d'ailleurs portés lors de la COP actuel
la RT n'aurait-il pas n'aurait-il plutôt
pas vocation à être l'opérateur un
service public ferroviaire
fort bien monsieur le candidat je vous
propose de répondre à mes collègues
merci merci monsieur le
Président peut-être pour répondre dans
dans l'ordre des
interventions monsieur dersin je suis
bien d'accord avec votre analyse et
votre euh sur l'appréciation que vous
portez sur le travail de Bernard Roman
il se trouve que je suis allé le voir
pour nous avons discuté ensemble je suis
all le voir à Lille
et on a eu une très belle discussion et
très très ouverte très franche et je je
je je confirme bien son engagement la
quiété de son engagement et la
discussion très ouverte que nous avons
eu tous les deux sur ces sujetsl euh qui
était vraiment excellente et qui m'a
ouvert pas mal de de de
perspectives confirmer des choses que je
pensais aussi euh sur le le sujet de la
de la CMP
euh pardon décision de la CMP le débat
sur les bus RATP j'ai effectivement été
hier informé de cette de ce de ce
point-là
euh je comprends l'inquiétude de l'
RT bien évidemment je la comprends
euh la compétence en question est
effectivement ce qu'on appelle une
compétence orpheline c'est-à-dire
qu'elle ne se rattache pas à des
fonctions qui exerce aujourd'hui la RT
qui est dans le domaine du contrôle
économique que ce soit financier
financier économique juridique euh on
rentre dans une dimension que j'ai bien
connu et étant ayant longtemps travaillé
au STIF donc cette questionl je la
connais particulièrement bien je vois
bien le sujet qui est derrière il y a un
vrai besoin derrière c'est évident ça
exige une compétence très particulière
effectivement il faut savoir comment
fonctionnent des des centres bus
autrement dit il faut savoir en en
machine en homme c'est une compétence
très particulière je comprends donc
l'inquiétude qui s'est manifestée pour
autant la loi est la loi
je ne suis pas
législateur donc je pense que il faut
bien ger les choses j'ai été président à
ce moment-là et encore une fois je suis
totalement solidaire bien sûr avec ce
qui a été dit parce que je comprends
très bien leurs
inquiétudes je pense qu'il faut en
parler davantage et bien avoir les
conditions aussi pour accéder à cette
compétence c'est évident si on ne pose
pas ce
débat sera bien la RT sera obligé de se
mobiliser sur ce sujetl important parce
qu'il va être important et assez à court
terme en fait hein c'est 24 25 26 et les
contentieux c'est pas théorique il vont
probablement émerger donc ça va être
effectivement une compétence à acquérir
encore une fois qui est nouvelle euh
dans un dans un système qui est tendu
avec des contraintes qu'on évoqué tout à
l'heure sur les moyens voilà donc je
comprends la posture la position prise
les logiquees mais encore une fois ça
n'est pas à la RT de déterminer ce que
est la loi voilà et donc je considère
personnellement que moi ce qui me
paraîtrait utile c'est que si vous
souhaitez de maintenir la commission
paritaire cette disposition paraît votre
tout à fait le travail légitime du
lgislateur sans aucun
souci le système va se mettre en place
progressivement 24 sera peut-être pas le
plus chargé 25 26 va venir et de de
revenir vers vous de de dire
concrètement quels sont les sujets que
cela posuse quels sont les choix que
nous faisons ça participe du du du point
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure à à faire en
toute transparence avec avec avec
l'autorité mais encore une fois euh
d'abord quand on a une compétence en
plus j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure pour une
autorité qui a besoin d'avoir des
compétences ça serait un peu singulier
de quelque part de les refuser entre
guillemets euh ce n'est pas notre rôle
mais en même temps il faut bien voir les
conséquences de çaela et et en parler en
toute transparence donc voilà très
clairement ma i là-dessus sujet dont
j'ai entendu parler plus plus
directement hier voilà donc j'ai pas
forcément un recul considérable je
comprends mais je comprends aussi
l'intention du législateur et voilà ce
que je peux dire à mon avis il y a de
quoi en parler prochainement je don la
parole oui merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais rebondir sur sur votre
réponse à la question posée par mon
collègue simplement pour préciser que
même si nous pouvons évidemment
comprendre les inquiétudes de d'un
certain nombre de membres de la RT euh
ça n'est pas nouveau la l la lum c'est
2019 c'est dire que l' RT a eu 4 ans HM
pour anticiper et mettre en œuvre les
compétences euh qui viseraiit à traiter
ce genre de litige potentiel qui ne
porte il faut le rappeler que sur euh en
tout cas dans le cadre de la CMP que
nous avons ce soir sur les 13 lots qui
sont mise à la concurrence prochainement
euh d'ailleurs on décale la date
d'ailleurs euh précisons que si nous
naavions pas si N remarqu de ma collègue
ce matin décaler cette
date la loi s'appliquait de fait et donc
la RT devait prendre en compte cette
cette compétence donc pour moi il peut
pas y avoir de débat et je trouve
regrettable que la position des
parlementaires la loi votée ici et à
l'Assemblée sur la loi la loi
d'orientation des mobilités fasse
l'objet dans le cadre d'une CMP
sur sur sur Île de France mobilité RATP
pour être clair sur les bus euh que que
la RT a pu prendre une position
d'influence auprès des parlementaires
des députés en l'occurrence pour leur
demander de modifier laalom en réalité
et je considère que ça n'est pas le rôle
de la RT de se positionner de cette
façon-là le rôle de l' RT c'est de jouer
son rôle de régulateur et et et de la
même façon qu'on ne demande pas
qu'onempêche pas ou qu'on évite à l'ARP
à l'arcom toute autorité indépendante y
compris la concurrence que vous vous
connaissez
bien les
autorités mettent en œuvre les missions
qui leur sont confiées voilà et et donc
il il n'appartient pas à mon sens à
l'autorité de définir ce qu'elle peut ou
ce qu'elle a envie de prendre à un
moment donné en fonction d' certain
nombre de critères voilà c'est le le
Parlement qui confie et ça a été le cas
dans le cadre de la Lom pour cette
compétence
particulière je comprends et je partage
il aurait probablement fallu mais encore
une fois aant découvert le problème hier
soir difficile pour moi d'en dire
beaucoup plus mais je pense qu'il aurait
fallu même si difficultés sont réelles
effectivement probablement en parler
plutôt davantage et peut-être en soutien
et en support de la discussion qu'on a
évoqué sur les moyens on demande pas des
moyens comme ça inabstracto on les
demande par rapport à quelque chose
effec euh voilà donc c'est tout ce que
je peux vous répondre sur ce point là
sur un sujet que que j'ai effectivement
découvert très récemment sur lequel je
suis je dire j'aurais peut-être procéder
autrement mais c'est facile pour moi de
le dire donc je me je me vraiment je me
garderai de de de de de cette approche
là qui serait un peu trop facile
euh sur les concessions autoroutières la
question est plusieurs fois c'est
effectivement un sujet majeur sur laquel
la RT est extrêmement mobilisé qui est
extrêmement consommateur de moyens de
compétences également dans des
conditions conflict actuelle vous
l'imaginez
bien effectivement la le le moment est
venu de la des fins de concession 10 ans
maintenant on va dire ça pour aller vite
c'est un moment extrêmement important
capital même voilà et je pense que dans
ce moment capital est important il
faudra développer une forte expertise
indépendante il faudra développer une
forte expertise indépendante ça me
paraît évident sur la question des fins
de concession faut déjà s'assurer
de une fin de concession ça veut dire
une remise gratuite au concédant on sait
bien que c'est toujours un moment
crucial dans toute
concession quels sont quel est l'état du
réseau remis c'est pas si simple que ça
même si en global très sincèrement et
c'est davantage des concessions le
réseau routier est quand même de bonne
qualité reste que des engagements on été
pris des autorisations parfois de péage
ont été mises à partir d'engagement faut
vérifier aussi que ces engagements là
sont bien tenus sont bien réalisés euh
dans par et ça ne peut être fait que par
une analyse technique extrêmement
précise pour ne pas se contenter de de
grandes considérations générales mais il
faut rentrer dans le fond dans le très
fond des dossiers ça c'est un travail
énorme ça c'est un travail je pense et
j'ai bien repéré comme étant un des
grands enjeux dans le mandat si vous
confirmez qui sera le mien
incontestablement de de travailler sur
cette fin de concession quel est le bon
modèle après je ne le connais pas je
n'ai pas d'état d'â dessus je pense
qu'il faut au contraire regarder tous
les scén le plus de scénarios possibles
et de converger ensuite avec bien sûr
les pouvoirs décisionnel hein les
pouvoirs publics sur le meilleur
scénario possible
euh mais la grande question aujourd'hui
c'est comment se terminent les
concessions comment encore quelques
avenant qui viennent sont correspondent
à un équilibre économique acceptable euh
notamment par le l'usager qui paye le
péage euh et comment introduit-on
peut-être là-dedans je va y venir des
dispositions qui sont plus à tourner
environnemental pour le coup puisque le
concédant peut demander un certain
nombre de choses qui relèv des des
sujets environnmentaux
énergétiques
monsieur fern vous m'avez posé la
question de la la transition écologique
je l'ai dit dans mon propos
effectivement tout à
l'heure la je pense qu'effectivement mon
sentiment est que les compétences se
développé un peu en Tage d'huile
progressive
et c'est une bonne chose en fonction des
besoins par secteur je pense que le
moment est venu c'est ce que dis dans
mon propos liminaire de d'avoir une
réflexion et peut-être pourquoi pas une
proposition de loi en ce sens sur un
régulateur redéfinir ce qu'est un
régulateur des transports pour
uniformiser pour étendre éventuellement
et pour surtout pour le mettre sous la
l'obligation qui est celle de la
transition écologique
énergétique parce qu'il y contribu
aujourd'hui pas que comme Monsieur
Jourdain fait de la prose mais mais
presque sans le savoir si je puis dire
et je pense que ça serait bien de
l'énoncer et de voir les compétences
qu'il faut développé dans le champ d'un
régulateur pas ailleurs hein mais il y a
des choses à dire et donc moi je serais
effectivement très favorable à ce que
une proposition de loi de de ce type
puisse
puisse prospérer
euh sur le sujet euh sur le sujet
aérien la question vous me disiez c'est
compliqué de rendre écologique un mode
qui est peut-être moins que d'autres
oui et non j'allais dire parce
qu'évidment il y a des besoins ariens
qui doivent être satisfaits qu'il soit
satisfait de la meilleure manière
possible et la question du régulateur
qui donne son mot sur la question des
redevances notamment que pay les
compagnies aériennes est important
puisque plus les redevances sont à leur
juste prix si je puis dire au juste coût
mieux les compagnies aériennes peuvent
disposer d'une d'une recette pour
pouvoir investir ils ont beaucoup
d'investissement à faire dans le domaine
de la dans le domaine de
la de l'environnement et du mode des
avions donc je pense qu'il y a un
rapport par ce moyenlà qui est pas pas
contestable
euh et puis les investissements
eux-mêmes des aéroports d'ailleurs
peuvent être regardés dans le cadre des
des contrats de
régulation que que sur lesquel on sera
ramené à se pencher
progressivement sur le rail
effectivement le le le le point clé
c'est évidemment la question du du de
l'investissement sur le réseau alors en
tant qu'opérateur fluvial je j'ai une
petite idée de ce que veut dire un
réseau sur lequel il y a pas eu assez
d'investissement je je je crois pouvoir
le dire et avoir vu les conséquences et
ça pendant des décennies he pas
maintenant tout ça ça se renverse pas en
5 minutes hein je crois pouvoir le dire
et l'avoir vu avec mes yeux de mes yeux
voilà voir en avoir été inquiet à titre
personnel je crois pouvoir dire aussi
que le fait de de d'avoir c'est pour ça
que j'avais autant insister parfois un
peu seul au début sur le fait qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait un contrat de même
nature que dans le ferroviaire dans le
dans le fluvial ça s'appelle le COP que
vous avez évoqué ça me paraît absolument
essentiel cette trajectoire est
essentielle quel que soit son montant il
faut avoir une trajectoire et ensuite
effidement il faut que le montant soit
compatible avec les les besoins
d'entretien de régénération d'un
réseau je pense que le travail fait par
la RT que j'ai consulté beaucoup
notamment milieu d'années de cette année
sur la question des projections de ce
que donnerait un niveau d'investissement
qui est aujourd'hui sous-jacant au
contrat de performance de de réseau qui
va être discuté euh et de ce qui serait
nécessaire pour maintenir en état et
être ne pas être dans une position de
paupérisation c'est le terme employé
même par la RT je pense qu'il a été
repris par l'Autorité de la concurrence
euh je pense que c'est une un travail
que sur lequel je me sens
particulièrement à l'aise pour la avoir
mené de mon côté avec modestie mes
déterminations dans le domaine du
fluvial euh donc il est clair et les
décisions évoquées par la première
ministre il y a pas très longtemps sur
la relance du ferroviaire me paraîtêtre
une bonne réponse qu' va falloir
maintenant intégrer dans les décisions
prises notamment dans la revoillure
prochaine du contrat de performance de
de des SNCF réseau avec non seulement
des chiffres des grands chiffres mais
également concrètement c'est c'est quoi
programme et comment le suit-on et je
pense qu'un régulateur a un rôle à jouer
dans le suivi de ce programme en toute
indépendance c'est pas à lui de juger la
pertinence d'un investissement par
rapport à un autre et comment on le
change c'est évidemment un travail de
quelque part de l'opérateur il engage sa
propre responsabilité dans cela pourut
pas se tromper mais par contre d'avoir
un suivi très précis des choix fait et
que tous les engagements pris soient
tenus me paraît être absolument capital
j'y veillerai et croyez bien que mon
expérience du fluvial m'a montré
l'intérêt voire plus vital de ce genre
de ces genre d'exercice toujours sur la
concurrence la concurrence vous
l'évoquiez je pense que l'ouverture à la
concurrence alors j'ai pas bien que
venant de de la concurrence au départ je
n'ai jamais eu une vision religieuse de
la concurrence la concurrence pour la
concurrence je ne vois pas très bien à
quoi ça sert c'est un c'est un moteur de
choses comme dans la vie de tous les
jours il a moment il y a besoin d'un
challenge si je puux dire pour
progresser on l'a tous vu les uns les
autres c'est un peu la même chose en
fait dans le domaine dans le domaine
économique
et je pense qu'il est important
notamment pour l'innovation qu'il y ait
sur une base régulière organisée
contrôler cont la concurrence sauvage me
paraît être qu'il faut écarter
complètement et destructeur par contre
quelque chose qui est
organisé se fait dans l'intérêt de tout
le monde y compris de l'opérateur actuel
j'en suis convaincu y
compris on l'a bien vu sur les la
concurrence va pas assez vite me dit-on
oui c'est vrai quelque part
faire la concurrence sur un réseau
ferroviaire c'est diablement plus
compliqué que sur un réseau de bus très
sincèrement donc il y a forcément
quelque chose qui est on peut regretter
mais c'est vrai en même temps c'est une
manœuvre si je peux dire extrêmement
difficile qui est exigeante autant pour
l'opérateur que pour l'autorité
organisatrice au combien extrêmement
exigeant et là-dessus un régulateur peut
aider l'autorité organisatrice à lire à
monter en compétence sur ces sujets là
mais en tout cas je pense que la
concurrence effectivement sans aucun
tabout pour moi euh est un moyen
d'améliorer euh les les les coûts à la
charge de l'usager c'est certain on l'a
déjà vu sur des à l'étranger ça a été
constaté euh à peu près partout quand la
concurrence a été faite et même dans
notre notre pays que ce soit les les
services librement organisés comme TGV
notamment sur Paris liyon euh ou que ce
soit sur les les quelques contrats de
services publics qui ont été renouvelés
par les autorités organ régionales on a
vu un intérêt on a vu que effectivement
il y avait plus d'offr et moins de coûts
voilà et ça c'est cet élément là il est
fondamental quiconque a besoin d'une
remise en cause organisée dans sa vie
personnelle comme dans dans l'économie
euh la qualité du réseau j'en ai parlé
sur les CERMES je pense que c'est projet
de loi PPL actuel et et c'est plus une
PPL d'ailleurs maintenant c'est une loi
c'est la loi c'est c'est la loi c'est la
loi voilà je suis un tout petit peu un
petit peu en retard encore dans mes
lectures elle est voté elle va revenir
là dans
quel ah oui donc c'est pas encore une
voix on a anticipé d'une semaine donc
j'avais bien de bonne base ça n pas
encore une
noix c'est ça euh donc bon je trouve
alors pour avoir beaucoup vécu ces
sujets en Île-de-France c'est savoir de
d'une bonne articulation en fait de mode
ferroviaire
structurant et des modes routiers ou
d'autres modes actifs structurés autour
d'une offre ferroviaire je crois que
c'est exactement la bonne question assez
fondamentale c'est pas toujours
extrêmement bien structuré c'est pas
toujours et quand j'étais au Steve
travailler beaucoup on avait mis en
place des des lignes de bus par exemple
sur des grandes distances de
rabattement et et c'est un sujet
important donc la la question de confier
à la RT la dans l'esprit que j'évoqué à
l'instant un suivi du plan
d'investissement sur 3 ans peut-être un
peu court mais 3 ans c'est déjà la
partie opérationnelle d'une visibilité à
plus long terme la question de la
fluidité des interopérabilités et des
multimodalités ça c'est quelque chose
que je connais bien aussi qui est
souvent le point difficile je l'ai
beaucoup vu aussi dans le fluvial la
question de
l'interopérabilité que chaque mode soit
pertinent dans son domaine soit efficace
dans son domaine de pertinence c'est un
sujet qui est un sujet majeur je pense
que la RT a un peu peut cette compétence
aujourd'hui ça gagnerait peut-être à
l'tendre davantage par rapport à à des
évolutions législatives que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure et la question de la
tarification effectivement spécifique
qui effectivement est est a important
donc je pense vraiment que cette loi va
apporter un coup de booster extrêmement
important avec des engagements pris par
ailleurs par la première ministre sur
cette question des grandes métropoles et
des transports grande métropole et et
environnant j'allais dire donc voilà mon
avis monsieur dei sur la taxe sur les
infrastructures évidemment c'est un
sujet d'abord juridiquement très
sensible vous le
savez dire même polémique voilà donc je
serai prudent dans mon expression je
vais pas juger sur le plan juridique sur
le plan de l'opportunité je m'exprime
allez gagner sa voix vous dites que vous
êtes vous
allez donnez-moi le meilleur résultat
possible
alors joker bon je vais peut-être le
prendre sur ce coup-là alors oui non
mais sincèrement euh on voit bien moi ça
me pose la question que ça évoque plutôt
en tant que régulateur c'est la question
en fait de l'organisation de des
contrats de concession en fait et
notamment de ce qu'on appelle le risque
fiscal ou le risque des décisions
extérieur qui sont légitimes notamment
quand il y a une baisse de de de l'impôt
sur les sociétés qui est générale
comment ça se répercute en gros voilà
est-ce que ça se répercute ça se
répercute pas vous connaissez le débat
il est d'une grande complexité le
Conseil d'État s'est exprimé euh ça pose
quand même la question de comment on
pense on repense ça renvoie à la
question sur l'avenir des des
concessions cette cette dimension là les
risques industriels les risques
opérationnels les risques trafic les
risques systémiques genre fiscaux
comment sont-il pris en compte et je
pense que là la question elle est
vraiment fondamentalement
fondamentalement loi du point de vue du
régulateur euh alors votre question
recettes est-ce que les recettes en fin
de concession ne peuvent pas être
réparti par
région oui je je je vois votre remarque
je je un sujet que je connais pas très
bien mais je sais pas je le sens pas
très redistributif quoi mais voilà ça va
forcément j'imagine que les régions qui
ont beaucoup d'autoroutes vont être
contentes de cette disposition et celles
qui n'en ont pas vont être opposé donc
voilà je j'ai petite un petit bémol de
ce côté-là mais je n'avoue que je n'ai
pas regardé plus en détail ce ce point
monsieur Monsieur jacin Merci de vos
remarques sur mon travail à VNF ça me
touche beaucoup c'est vrai que ça pas
été simple je veux juste dire que sur le
réseau grand test que vous connaissez
bien que nous connaissons bien
l'orientation départ qu'on m'a remise
était pas celle qui m suivie par rapport
à l'indépendance pas du tout c
effectivement de fermer les
canaux j'ai dit en voyant ce que ça pe
poser comme problème et en voyant que c
pas que du transport des Canau c'est
bien autre chose qu'il fallait prendre
le sujet autrement je suis j'ai j'ai
porté cette parole qui était dissidente
voilà euh la région les régions les
collectivités m'ont beaucoup aidé à le
faire je dois dire et ont été des je su
quelques discussions avec le président
de la Région grandest de l'époque
c'était un peu un peu un peu fort mais
on s'est dit on va traiter le problème
autrement et donc je suis allé porter un
message différent et on a changé
l'organisation complète sur ces
sujets-là on a signé beaucoup de choses
et on est encore en train d'élargir le
partenariat de VNF avec la région
grandes comme avec d'autres régions
comme avec d'autres régions on va le
faire prochainement sur VOG franchecé
donc je et là pour le coup c'était pas
du tout la doxa ou la ce qui était
indiqué au départ vous le savez voilà je
crois avoir contribué beaucoup à la
faire changer en tout indépendance ou en
tout cas dans le mandat qui était le
mien de de directeur général de
VNF alors au fonctionnaire vous dites
bon c'est bien gentil tout ça mais ça
pass son temps obéir un ministre alors
je suis au fonctionnaire je suis pas
d'accord avec ça personnellement voil je
pense que ça passe son temps à éclairer
un ministre je pass ça passe son temps à
donner des informations un ministre bien
évidemment il a le pouvoir politique
c'est totalement légitime et donc ça
m'est arrivé même je peux vous dire je
donnerai pas ministre mais de dire je ne
suis pas d'accord je pens c'est pas la
bonne position et je peux dire qu'on a
eu un débat avec le ministre je dir pas
lequel mais c'est vrai et mais oui mais
c'est ma décision politique et je le
comprends complètement n'empêche que
tous les arguments techniques sont
exposés et être aux ordres ça serait de
ne pas les
exposer comme une art est là pour donner
des des orientations pour éclairer des
orientations pas les données les
éclairer donc à au fonctionnaire c'est
un homme qui éclaire et je tiens à dire
aussi comme je dit je n'ai pas passé mon
temps en administration centrale
finalement c'est la minorité de mon
temps de travail je l'ai passé d'
établissement qui sont indépendants j'ai
qu'ils sont vraiment je peux vous dire
parfois même un peu opposés hein on va
se le dire euh et j'ai aussi s passé
dans une collective territoriale pas la
moindre
île- de France mobilité la relation avec
le ministère des Transports était pas
toujours simple je peux vous dire
notamment sur le réseau du Grand Paris
pas toujours simple et j'enis des termes
mesurés ça m'a pas posé de problème du
tout j'étais complètement loyal avec aux
collectivités qui m'employait à ce
moment-là si j'avais eu un état d'â j'en
serais parti tout simplement c'est comme
ça que je
fonctionne et je serai dans le même
loyauté à l'égard d'une autorité
évidemment qui qui qui sera mon mon sur
lequel j'assurerai une
présidence la concurrence trop limitée
j'en ai parlé rapidement je pense que
oui bien évidemment on ne change pas un
système
historique très facilement et on le voit
là mais je pense qu'il faut veiller et
c'est le rôle de la RT à ce que toutes
les conditions permettant d'innover et
de faire venir de nouveaux opérateurs
pour innover ou que l'opérateur
historique innove lui-même parce qu'il
en est diablement capable euh soit
autorisé soit permis donc qu'il y ait
pas de blocage à l'entrée que pour euh
opérer quelque chose il y a pas des
informations euh qui soient pas
accessibles bref que le les règles du
jeu soient respectées c'est un peu un
rôle d'arbitre que le jeu se déroule
mais que les règles soient respectées
euh sur le le discours de la méthode sur
la la fin des autoroutes je pense avoir
commencé à le dire je pense premièrement
c'est
les les concessions s'achèvent dans 10
ans c'est demain matin en fait et la fin
des concessions est est un challenge
redoutable qu'on a jamais connu
finalement on n jamais connu ça c'est un
challenge redoutable pour faire en sorte
que les obligations que les
concessionnaires doivent mettre en œuvre
soit mise en œuvre
réellement ça exige de rentrer loin pour
le savoir pour le dire sont redoutables
pour imaginer la suite tout est ouvert
personnellement bien qu'il a on commencé
ma carrière dans ces sujets j'ai pas non
plus les concessions de toute façon s'il
y en a encore elles seront différentes
on sera pas sur un rythme
d'investissement aussi important les
concessions ont été au départ créé pour
investir bien sûr exploiter mais il
fallait franchir un pas important il a
été fait une concession d'exploitation
ou un système d'exploitation n'est pas
le même pas la même durée pas les mêmes
modalités c'est très très différent en
fait voilà et puis enfin le rôle de la
concurrence dans transition monsieur
Barros et le rôle du sur le fr
ferroviaire le rôle de de la concurrence
ben je viens de le dire effectivement
c'est un moyen d'innover sur tous les
plans il doit être contrôlé c'est
certain régulé c'est le bon terme pour
qu'il se fasse de l'intérêt général et
je pense que il peut y avoir par ce
moyen-là effectivement un des
innovations qui portent sur
l'environnement et de de rendre plus
attractif encore les modes
le transport collectif en les rendant je
tout à l'heure de meilleure qualité
mieux coordonné en multimodalité moins
coûteux souvent il a la question du coût
qui qui joue et et et je pense que la
concurrence on l'a vu ailleurs et on le
voit même en France contribue à cela
mais elle doit être régulée elle doit
être organisée et je pense que
l'opérateur historique il a aussi tout
intérêt et d'ailleurs il l'a montré
d'être extrêmement efficace dans ce
jeu-là euh sur le frê ferroviaire je
connais bien le sujet du du fret en
général
ferroviaire en particulier je crois que
le fr ferroviaire effectivement bon a a
connu des des des vicissitudes ces
dernières décennies comme le freed
fluvial d'ailleurs c'est un mouvement
général des modes lourd tout simplement
je pense pas que l'ouverture à la
concurrence explique cela c'est même
venu après l'ouverture à la concurrence
j'ai même tendance à penser qu'elle a
plutôt stabilisé enfin si on garde les
trajectoires la la perte de la perte de
part de marché a plutôt été stabilisé
avec une bonne vingtaine d'opérateurs
supplémentaires avec une un rôle moteur
encore joué par l'opérateur historique
et je pense donc notamment la place du
du combiné qui a qui qui a pris une
place importante qui est de 40 %
maintenant donc je pense que ces
innovations cette évolution ont fait que
la part du du du FR même si aujourd'hui
elle est pas suffisante évident a cessé
de décliner et c'est presque
contemporain de l'arrivée de la
concurrence et je pense que ça c'est un
point important et
enfin ben non je je crois avoir à peu
près répondu à ensemble de vos questions
monsieur le rapporteur est-ce que j'en
ai laissé certain d'entre vous très bien
merci je vais donner la parole à Simon
usena et puis après à Denis
s merci monsieur le
Président trois points monsieur le le
directeur merci en tout cas pour pour
vos propos je vais me permettre de
revenir tout d'abord sur le sujet de de
l'indépendance j'ai bien entendu les les
réponses aux questions des collègues
alors évidemment l'indépendance on
l'entend dans dans toutes ces directions
y compris à l'égard du Parlement donc de
ce point de vue-là vous avez toute
liberté pour faire valoir une parole
singulière pour autant dans le respect
de la loi nous serons évidemment et nous
sommes les uns les autres intransigeents
parce que notre République tient aussi à
cette condition là et donc demain si
vous êtes confirmé en tant que président
de la RT vous aurez aussi un rôle dans
le le respect de la loi donc je pense
que ce message là il doit être
clairement clairement assumé et passé
c'est une condition aussi de notre
réussite collective sur le
ferroviaire par rapport à à vos propos
vous avez repris justement un mot sur
lequel je je tenais à vous interroger
figurait dans le rapport de juillet 2023
signé par le le président par intérim
Philippe Richer euh sur les scénarios de
long terme pour le réseau ferroviaire
français qui dit clairement je cite le
maintien des trajectoires
d'investissement actuels tel que prévu
par le contrat de performance pour le
renouvellement et la modernisation du
réseau entraînerait inhévitablement le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure dans une
spirale de popérisation industriel le
mot industriel a a aussi son importance
donc je je souhaitais avoir quelques
compléments euh de votre part sur ce
sujet parce que vous avez évoqué les
annonces en particulier de la première
ministre les fameux 100 milliards euh
les uns les autres régulièrement nous
nous interrogeons sur la réalité de ces
montants et sur leur déploiement
effectif en particulier s'agissant des
CERMES donc on rappelle le l'engagement
qui a été pris c'est 10 CERMES déployés
dans les 10 ans pour un montant estimé
15 milliards d'euros or on a eu
l'occasion là aussi d'en débattre dans
le cadre de de l'examen de de la PPL sur
le sujet pour l'instant les premiers
montants sur la période
2023-2027 donc la moitié de la période
concernée c'est 10 % de cette somme mis
sur la table en l'occurrence un peu plus
de 760 millions d'euros par l'État et
l'équivalent par la région donc ça veut
dire 1,5 milliards sur les 15 milliards
alors qu'on parle de 50 % de la durée 5
ans sur les 10 ans donc là il y a une
incohérence majeure comment vous vous
abordez ce sujet puis dernière question
j'ai j'ai bien u les les trois priorités
ou les enjeux que que vous évoqueiez à
titre personnel je les aurais organisé
dans un sens
différent de mon point de vue la qualité
de service rendu aux usagers c'est
l'élément central aujourd'hui c'est
l'élément central parce que si on veut
en effet aller plus loin sur la
transition écologique et non pas sur la
maîtrise des dépenses mais plutôt sur
l'efficacité des dépenses face à
l'urgence climatique l'élément ément
pivot c'est la qualité de service rendu
aux usagers parce que c'est parce que
nousous aurons des services de transport
qui seront attractifs que derrière nous
aurons des effets leviers en particulier
sur la transition et et sur l'efficacité
des dépenses donc par rapport à cette
qualité de service quelle approche vous
entendez déployer pour justement prendre
en compte aussi ces ces retours terrain
dans cette approche décentralisée que
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure et et
par rapport à une une vision de la
concurrence qui doit pas être idéalisée
on a eu l'occasion les uns les autres de
le dire notamment dans le cadre de la
pplratp il faut travailler aussi sur le
sujet de
l'attractivité des métiers sur le cadre
social il y a des enjeux de recrutement
donc tout ça concourrant à la qualité de
service donc je souhaitais avoir
quelques précisions de votre part sur ce
sujet je vais donner la parole à
Den merci président monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
potentiel
euh je le souhaite
euh j'ai bien compris les les trois
visions
euh que vous nous avez exprimé de votre
mission dont vous souhaitez réussir les
différentes transitions euh qu'elles soi
énergétique qu'elle soit écologique vous
souhaitez euh euh réussir euh la mise en
concurrence euh et à
terme baisser le coût pour l'usager et
puis vous souhaitez également et ça a
été dit par notre collègue dernier
orateur euh appuyer insister sur le
service rendu à l'usager à aucun moment
Président je n'ai entendu le mot
sécurité or pour ma part je considère
que l'une de vos missions et l'une des
exigences très fortes que vous devrez
que vous devrez avoir demain envers tous
les opérateurs qui soumissionneront euh
c'est d'abord l'exigence de sécurité
parce que personne n'en parle et c'est
quand arrive le drame l'accident que on
se pose des questions sur la sécurité
donc très simplement président quel sera
votre politique en matière de sécurité
parce que même si ça rentre dans le
service rendu à l'usager il me semble
que vous devez avoir vous en tant
qu'autorité de régulation des exigences
très fortes en matière de sécurité
merci Monsieur le candidat je vous
propose de répondre à mes deux
collègues beaucoup
euh monsieur hna la la monsieur le
sénateur le rôle dans le respect de la
loi euh est évidemment complètement
central pour pour pour la RT quand on
évoque tout ce que
j'évoque notamment sur la mise en
concurrence c'est un aspect de la loi
donc on est en plein dans la mise en
œuvre dans le respect de la loi donc un
régulateur ne on a eu les débats tout à
l'heure sur la question de l'île-fance
et des bus Île-de-France avec Monsieur
messieurs les sénateurs j'ai dit la loi
est la loi est un régulateur est là pour
appliquer la loi et en estêt même un
porteur au premier chef en lui-même et
en relation avec l'exécutif mais aussi
le législatif pour rendre compte
régulièrement de ce qui se fait y
compris des dispositions législatives
qui sont bien ou mal respecté ça me
paraît être la base de de de de ce
travail là du mien en particulier euh
sur le le scénario long terme qu'on a
évoqué du rapport de de d'avant l'été
euh il est très intéressant ce rapport
très très important et encore une fois
je il m'a beaucoup parlé dans mon rôle
actuel effectivement le le mon employé
le terme de popérisation je vais repris
d'ailleurs industrielle euh popérisation
pardon industrielle je pense que que
c'est le bon terme le bon terme est pris
parce qu'on voit par exemple que des
projets qui avancent beaucoup plus vite
à l'étranger comme les dispositifs de de
téléconduite dispositifs de conduite
modernisé ou d'utilisation de rTMS entre
en France en un déploiement beaucoup
plus lent que dans d'autres pays c'est
une illustration de ce qu'on peut
qualifier de paupérisation d'un
fonctionnement qui n'est plus qui ne
serait plus dans les normes
industrielles et techniques euh le
moment venu en en Europe donc c'est
c'est clair c'est clairement un des
sujets importants et nul doute que si
j'avais été président à ce moment-là je
n'urais eu aucun problème pour soutenir
cette cette position d'autant que je
l'ai pas mal soutenu aussi encore une
fois en tant que BNF parce que j'ai une
petite idée de ce qu'est la poporisation
industrielle euh d'un autre opérateur
donc euh c'est quelque chose euh c'est
quelque chose d'important et à VNF
j'aurais d'ailleurs apprécié que la RT
parle aussi de la pourisation de du
vouviel ça permet de donner un un poids
à ce sujet-là vous dites effectivement
que les les investissements les les les
montants sont aujourd'hui très
inférieurs à ce qui é évoqué je je ça m
pas échapper non plus mon travail sera
de revenir là-dessus en tant qu'art en
tant que régulateur bien évidemment ça
va de soi ça va de soi pour moi ça ne
fait aucun doute euh vous parliez tout à
l'heure que j'ai vous auriez dit
autrement le problème de qualité de
service vous l'EZ inversé je veux dire
que l'ORD dans lequel je donnais n'était
pas du tout prioritaire ni à côté ni de
l'autre on peut le prendre par les deux
sens comme on veut euh la qualité de
service encore une ma carrière je pense
était très tournée sur cela évidemment
est essentiel est un élément central
euh je pense que le rôle du régulateur
qui est peut-être pas encore très
prignant sur ces sujetsl gagnera là
aussi à être précisé et à se développer
notamment à travers la la multimodalité
multimodalité et souvent et on le verra
sur les CERMES et un peu un point de
fragilité du système français que ce
soit dans le fret ou dans le passager
c'est c'est évident je suis un
grandenant de dire chaque mode a sa zone
de pertinence faut pas forcément que les
modes cherchent à tout faire mais encore
faut-il qu'il soit bien articulé et
parfois quand j'évoqué tout à l'heure
que c'est un régulateur mode par mode et
pas un régulateur global c'est un peu à
ça je faisais allusion cette question du
système et de comment dans le domaine de
compétence qui est de la RT bien entendu
mais comment on est présent sur la
question du système entendu
multimodalité et cetera je pense que
c'est un sujet qui existe aujourd'hui et
qui va se renforcer notamment à travers
les CERMES mais pas que
et ne serait-ce que dans le sujet par
exemple de de l'information voyageurs
des systèmes d'information des systèmes
de tarification il faut pas que ça
devienne une on le sait bien je l'ai
beaucoup connu quand j'étais au sttif en
île-de-fance on a fait beaucoup
d'intégration parce qu'effectivement un
voyageur attend une information intégrée
il va pas simplement savoir quelle est
la bonne information de l'opérateur où
il est à l'instant où il est il veut
savoir sur laité de son parcours et donc
là-dessus je pense que l' RT a
effectivement sur la qualité
sur niveau d'information mis à
disposition leur
certitude et leur qualité encore une
fois aura un rôle important
euh madame la sénatrice vous avez raison
j'ai pas évoqué le terme de sécurité
c'est un élément pour moi de la qualité
de service tout simplement basiquement
alors ça va un peu au-delà de ça j'en
suis bien conscient juste vous dire il y
a T public qui est qui s'occupe de
qualité ça s'appelle le PSF sécurité
ferroviaire étaissement public sécurité
ferroviaire et je sais déjà je pense que
je continuerai à amplifier cela je sais
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait pas très
longtemps une réunion un travail commun
art EPSF ceux qui s'occupent
principalement et uniquement de la
sécurité ferroviaire et dit aussi si
c'est un vaste sujet très vaste sujet en
tant que tel pour pas se gaspiller
là-dedans mais par contre on travaille
en partenariat avec le PSF c'est qui
sont qui sont basés à Amien c'est
évidemment un sujet qui est qui est pas
du tout en dehors du scope à telle
enseigne qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
partenariat art EPS pour aller dans le
sens de ce que vous évoqueiez vous aviez
raison merci s'il n'y a plus de
questions ni bien je vais demander au
candidats de se retirer et puis nous
allons procéder au
vote merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci merci